in der damen und herren und zurück im
bundestag der jetzt gerade angefangen
hat über den bundeswehreinsatz im kosovo
zu sprechen die verlängerung dieses
einsatzes bis zu 400 bundeswehrsoldaten
sollen dort ein weiteres jahr
stationiert werden im moment sind 70
soldaten die dort eingesetzt sind der k4
auftrag ist hier schon über 20 jahre
einer der längsten denen die bundeswehr
erfüllt und herrn kann es genau von der
afg hat jetzt das wort er ist mitglied
im verteidigungsausschuss
konsequenzen hat man aus dieser zeit
gezogen welche alternativen ansätzen
wurden abgewogen sollen denn
ausländische truppenkontingent wirklich
müssen alle ewigkeit im kosovo
stationiert bleiben wie soll man der
grassierenden korruption her werden und
wie soll dieser staat jemals in die lage
versetzt werden seine eigene öffentliche
ordnung eigenständig durchzusetzen und
viel wichtiger noch meine damen und
herren wann endet endlich der einsatz
für unsere streitkräfte dann vergessen
sie nicht auch im kosovo ließen 27
deutsche soldaten ihr leben und tausende
kehrten heim mit körperlichen und
seelischen verletzungen für diese
kameraden meine damen und herren für
diese kameraden günter krieg niemals an
und wir sind es ihnen schuldig dass sie
nicht vergessen werden
es ist leider typisch für die
altparteien regierung unseres landes
keine exit strategien entworfen werden
selbst nach jahrzehnten es wird vor
allem für die soldaten so als verlasse
man sich hier in berlin die wir auf
andere internationale akteure und
bündnispartner und als würde man
insgeheim hoffen dass fakten
schlussendlich von jemanden anderen
geschaffen werden und damit damit man
keine eigenständige deutsche position
einnehmen und vielleicht ja sogar mal
führung beweisen muss und wie so ein
einsatz ohne ende dann am schluss eben
doch sein ende finden kann das haben wir
tragischerweise letztes jahr in
afghanistan gesehen die lehre muss doch
sein dass wir als westeuropäer solche
ebene kulturellen und religiösen
konflikte wieder gänzlich verinnerlichen
geschweige denn lösen können das muss im
endeffekt von den einheimischen völkern
selbst geleistet werden man kann sie von
den historischen rahmen nicht lösen und
mit ein wenig state building und
zivilgesellschaft industrie weg
moderieren letztendlich kann man sich an
lösungsfindung zwar beteiligen aber in
erster linie hat die deutsche
bundesregierung im falle von k vor einen
weg zu finden wie wir unsere
streitkräfte wieder zur
landesverteidigung in die heimat holen
können dass
das muss priorität bleiben die so groß
angekündigte verteidigungspolitische
wende muss endlich ernst genommen werden
doch allen ebenen eingeleitet werden so
lange sie aber deutsche soldaten in
auslandseinsätze schicken wollen kann
davon keine rede sein wir als fdp wollen
dies ändern und deshalb werden wie einer
fortsetzung des mandats natürlich nicht
zustimmen vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege genau
[Applaus]
als nächster redner hält das wort
kollege ulrich lechte fdp
ulrich lechte von fdp-obmann im
auswärtigen ausschuss für seine fraktion
sagte präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen eingebettet immer zwischen afd
und linke macht es immer ganz besonders
viel freude hier sprechen zu dürfen der
kv einsatz ist nicht nur der am längsten
währende
bundeswehreinsatz und auch aufgrund der
gegenwärtigen situation in der ukraine
und dem imperialistischen
agieren russlands aus
sicherheitspolitischer perspektive ein
enorm wichtiger einsatz
instabilität im westbalkan dürfen und
werden wir unter keinen umständen
zulassen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
deshalb werbe ich auch heute hier dafür
dass wir den bundeswehreinsatz im kosovo
unvermindert fortsetzen und unseren
beitrag zur regionalen sicherheit im
kosovo weiterhin leisten das erwarten im
übrigen auch unsere partner
denn der westbalkan ist derzeit von
hohem interesse und darf nicht zur arena
russischer großmacht fantasien werden
dies müssen wir frühzeitig erkennen und
bei bedarf auch entschlossen eingreifen
daher bin ich den aktuell rund 70
deutschen soldatinnen und soldaten im
kampfeinsatz dankbar dass sich vor ort
sind und zur stabilisierung und
deeskalation entscheidend beitragen und
verantwortung in unserem auftrag
übernehmen ich bin davon überzeugt dass
wir weiterhin präsenz und sichtbarkeit
im westbalkan zeigen müssen um
sicherheit und frieden dauerhaft zu
garantieren
denn auch wenn die lage derzeit
verhältnismäßig ruhig ist muss das nicht
so bleiben um das kosovo weiter zu
stabilisieren und bei der entwicklung zu
einer demokratischen rechtsstaatlichen
multi ethnischen und friedlichen
republik zu unterstützen benötigt es
jetzt meiner meinung nach dringend
konkretere schritte hierzu zähle ich vor
allem den beitritt kosovos zum europarat
die seit jahren geforderte und längst
überfällige visaliberalisierung und die
anerkennung kosovos durch die
verbliebenen fünf eu staaten namentlich
spanien zypern griechenland slowenien
und rumänien
die bedenken dieser länder müssen wir
angehen und diese gemeinsam ausräumen
die zeit dafür ist jetzt europa muss
hier fest zusammenstehen und sollte auch
in dieser angelegenheit
geschlossenheit demonstrieren außerdem
braucht es endlich einen zielführenden
dialog zwischen dem kosovo und serbien
der nicht an nummernschildern und strom
streits scheitert zu einem beiden
ländern ein eu-beitritt ermöglicht der
jedoch so ehrlich muss man an dieser
stelle seien für das kosovo aktuell
greifbarer ist als für serbien das ist
mit dem herzigen serbischen system nur
schwer zu vereinbaren dass diese in
unsere demokratische eu eintreten
die historische chance den kosovo in den
europarat aufzunehmen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen dürfen wir nicht vertun
denn das ist auch ein signal der
anerkennung der bisher getätigten
anstrengungen kosovos der präsident der
parlamentarischen vereinigungen cox es
war eigentlich nur der parlamentarischen
versammlung europarats cox war diese
woche in berlin wir haben mit ihm
gesprochen und er ist dem ansinnen
gegenüber positiv eingestellt
schließlich erfüllt das kosovo bereits
heute 80 prozent der anforderungen aus
dem abschluss des stabilisierungs und
assoziierungsabkommens der eu möchte
noch in diesem jahr die eu
mitgliedschaft beantragen darüber habe
ich auch bei einem persönlichen
austausch mit der kosovarischen
außenministerin frau der welt schwarz
gesprochen die mir zudem versichert hat
dass das kosovo sich auch weiterhin an
den europäischen sanktionen gegen
russland beteiligen wird und als partner
an unserer seite unterseite der
europäischen und internationalen
gemeinschaft steht deshalb möchte ich
nochmals betonen dass kosovo wünscht
sich die fortsetzung unseres engagement
denn der bestehende frieden in der
region ist fragil josip juratovic nicht
wir hatten dort eine gemeinsame reise
vor zwei jahren im der letzte perioden
unternommen und ist da ist auch kein
failed state was er hier bleibt eben
behauptet wurde und ist vor dem
hintergrund des russischen
angriffskrieges in der ukraine mehr als
je gefährdet wir haben bereits einmal
den fehler begangen über russlands
expansionistische politik im
postsowjetischen raum hinweg zu sehen
und auf russland als verlässlichen
partner zu vertrauen dies darf uns auf
keinen fall ein weiteres mal passieren
russland hat nämlich mit dem
zivilisationsbruch vom 24 februar fakten
geschaffen die unumkehrbar sind und auf
jahre wenn ich sogar auf jahrzehnte
nachwirken werden es ist also nicht nur
im europäischen interesse sondern vor
allem auch im deutschen interesse dass
wir jegliche bestrebungen russlands den
kosovo zu destabilisieren im keim
ersticken und die stabilität
rechtsstaatlichkeit und demokratie im
westbalkan gemeinsam entschlossen
verteidigen es wird sie nicht
überraschen wir stimmen mit voller
übereinstimmung mit diesem mandat heute
hier zu unseren soldaten gekauft vielen
dank herr kollege liste
als nächstes erhält die das wort die
kollegin salinas die fraktion die linke
chinas tisch ist die opfer der linken im
verteidigungsausschuss
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren unter der mitwirkung
deutschlands hat die nato
damals die provinz kosovo und mit hirn
durch einen völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg von der republik
jugoslawien
abgespalten die resolution 12 44 der
vereinten nationen gilt aber um sie
schreibt die souveränität und die
territoriale integrität
jugoslawiens und seines nachfolge
staates fest und gibt dem kosovo darin
auf substanzielle autonomie innerhalb
serbiens meine damen und herren weder in
der ukraine noch im kosovo kann durch
völkerrechtswidrige angriffskriege
demokratie menschenrechte und ein
friedliches zusammenleben herbeigebombt
werden
im kosovo werden regelmäßig wahl
ermöglicht das politische system ist
völlig in diskussion ahl korruption ist
auf einem hohen niveau und nazi
kollaborateure vi safa de war wird von
großen teilen der bevölkerung bis hin
auf die regierungsbank verehrt decks eva
dewor dem zweiten weltkrieg
dem ss division skanderbeg
gebildet hat und für verbrechen an juden
bekannt ist und es ist wirklich
ungeheuerlich dass nur durch einen
immensen öffentlichen druck die
finanzierung durch die europäische union
und das entwicklungszentrum der
vereinten nationen das nur dadurch
behindert werden könnte dass das
ehemalige wohnhaus dieses faschisten
tatsächlich zu einem kulturzentrum
ausgebaut wird und dass die regierung in
pristina daran weiter festhält ist noch
ein weiterer skandal für uns linke ist
ganz klar der faschisten verehrt hat mit
demokratie und menschenrechten nichts zu
tun und wird auch nicht in die
europäische union und
das scharping und fischer also rot grün
wurde dieser künstliche staat geschaffen
durch eine hohe verbreitung von
kleinwaffen ist er bekannt man möge
aktuell auf die webseite des auswärtigen
amtes chance diskriminierung und
verfolgung von roma serben und anderen
minderheiten ist auf der tagesordnung
alleine 2008 bis 2018 haben 30 prozent
der bevölkerung das kosovo verlassen
vergangenes jahr wäre es fast erneut zu
einem bewaffneten konflikt aufgrund von
auge nummernschildern gekommen meine
damen und herren weder deutsche waffen
noch kriegseinsätze schaffen demokratie
frieden und dass sie ausgerechnet
dieses land durch einen
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
geschaffen haben und vor serbien jetzt
fordern diesen völkerrechts buch
anzuerkennen macht sie nicht
glaubwürdiger im gegenteil sie selbst
haben putin seinerseits die besten
argumente für seinen völkerrechts wie
kritik geliefert ob wir uns links ganz
klar es gibt keine gucken und keine
schlechten völkerrechtswidrige kriege
wir verurteilen sie alle probleme dieses
mandat ab
[Applaus]
ja und dass die linke dieses mandat die
mandatsverlängerung kfor im kosovo der
einsatztruppen ablehnt dass bis jetzt
keine große überraschung so weingarten
jetzt die spd
präsident frau wehrbeauftragte liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren ihre kollegin mastix ist die
kollegen da rechts nichts mehr
dazulernen in diesem leben daran haben
wir uns gewöhnt aber dass sie so stolz
drauf sind seit 1990 nichts dazugelernt
zu haben das macht mich schon traurig
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
westbalkan ist von strategischem
interesse für die sicherheit europas und
der bundesrepublik deutschland
die sozialdemokratischen
bundestagsfraktion begrüßt deshalb
ausdrücklich dass unsere streitkräfte
zur stabilisierung im kosovo beitragen
seit 1999 sichern sie als teil der
kosovo force kfor den frieden in dieser
region
aktuell als teil von rund 3.800
soldatinnen und soldaten aus 28 staaten
auf der basis eines un-mandats unter dem
kommando des ungarischen generalmajors
ferenc k 31 mit rund 6000 kräften heute
im sechzigsten einsatzkontingent in
wesentlich geringerem umfang ich danke
auch allen dank angehörigen der
bundeswehr durch die durch ihren
persönlichen tatkräftigen einsatz für
die freiheit in kosovo und die
sicherheit in der region eingetreten
sind und das weiterhin tun
das gilt nicht nur für die aktuell rund
70 kräfte vor ort sondern auch für die
einsatzführung hier in deutschland und
bei der nato wir wollen unsere
verantwortung der regen in der region
gegenüber weiter gerecht werden und
unseren beitrag zur kv weiter verlängern
denn hier im kern des ehemaligen
jugoslawien das nicht mehr existiert
zeigen sich auch der zeigt sich der
russische machtanspruch in besonderer
weise russland und serbien greifen die
nationale identität des kosovo an für
uns ist aber kosovo ein beispiel für das
streben nach freiheit und
selbstbestimmung und einer eigenen
nationalen identität
und es geht auch um die frage wer auf
dem balkan zu europa steht bei kosovo
ist das keine frage bei seinem
nachbarland serbien schon sie habe ihren
pendelt den bedenklicher weise zwischen
seinem anspruch teil der eu werden zu
wollen und gleichzeitig der versuchung
außenposten russlands und chinas in
europa zu sein beides gleichzeitig geht
aber nicht serbien muss sich entscheiden
wo seine zukunft liegt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen zur
verantwortung einer führungs nation
gehört die strategische die
stabilisierung des westbalkans durch
russland nicht zuzulassen das verstehen
wir solange serbien sich nicht klar von
putin distanziert besteht dieses risiko
auch weiter konstant hingegen hat der
kosovo als land bereits große
fortschritte gemacht wie sehen die
bemühungen der regierung sich gegen
korruption einzusetzen und die
westbindung des landes weiter auszubauen
die militärischen sicherheitskräfte die
kosovo security force wie auch die
kosovarische polizei
agieren zunehmend professioneller und
sicherer unser ziel ist dass der kosovo
noch stärker für seine eigene sicherheit
sorgen kann die bundesrepublik steht
dabei entschlossen an der seite des
landes
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen heute
geht es darum dass kurs oder sculfor
mandat zu verlängern um frieden in
kosovo und der welt westbalkan zu
sichern um der aggressiven einflussnahme
russlands einhalt zu gebieten und und
die wirtschaftliche und soziale
entwicklung der regierung zu ermöglichen
bitten wir sie darum der verlängerung
des mandates in einem umfang von bis zu
400 kräften zuzustimmen herzlichen dank
also bis zu 400 kräften insgesamt sind
28 nationen beteiligt im moment sind die
drei 1400 soldaten vor ort 70 von der
bundeswehr
seien sie uns wie nächste rednerin ist
kollegin annette widmann mauz cdu csu
fraktion und eva högl die
wehrbeauftragte des deutschen
bundestages ist zu dieser debatte auch
erschienen wurde gerade begrüßt annette
widmann mauz jetzt für die cdu csu im
auswärtigen ausschuss
dann wenn sie auch die kleinen knopf
jetzt geht es auch so
ja sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen wir haben
lange bei uns in dem glauben gewählt
dass der jugoslawienkrieg der letzte auf
europäischen boden sein würde heute 23
jahre später herrscht wieder krieg in
europa ein krieg der schlimmste
erinnerungen an die massaker und
kriegsverbrechen dabei kein kriege weckt
an dass die linke heute wieder dem
ukrainisch krieg russland auf eine
wirklich profitable und weise
relativiert zeigt auf welcher seite sie
in der geschichte stehen bis zum
heutigen tag
dieser dieser russische angriffskrieg
erreicht in seinem politischen
dimensionen weit über die ukraine hinaus
auch auf dem westbalkan sind diese
spannungen zu spüren deshalb ist es
notwendig und richtig dass der
westbalkan nicht in den hintergrund
gerät sondern auch und gerade jetzt
unsere besondere aufmerksamkeit hat in
einer ohnehin schon volatilen region in
der immer wieder ethnische spannungen
aufnahmen hätte russland leichtes spiel
wenn wir als europäer und nato dem
nichts entgegen setzen und unseren
partnern vor ort nicht zur seite stehen
ja wir bereiten heute über die
fortführung der nato mission im kosovo
und anschließend über vor althea in
bosnien herzegowina
die präsenz der nato im kosovo ist für
die gesamte region und für europa
wichtig denn sie ist gerade auch ein
schutzschild gegen die expandierende
politische einflussnahme russlands und
anderer auf dem balkan und sie liegt
deshalb in unserem
sicherheitspolitischen und strategischen
interesse die lage im kosovo hat sich
seit 1999 im übrigen deutlich
stabilisiert und verbessert und unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten haben mit ihrem
einsatz im k4 mandat einen wichtigen
beitrag dazu geleistet die bundeswehr
genießt vor ort einen hervorragenden ruf
und deshalb gebührt ihr und den
soldatinnen und soldaten unser dank und
unsere andere kind auch
die kosovarischen streitkräfte haben
sich mit der unterstützung der nato
deutlich weiterentwickelt auch wenn es
noch nicht zum vollständigen und
eigenständigen schutz für das gesamte
staatsgebiet ausreicht das hat damit zu
tun dass die konflikte und des
eskalationspotenzial in der gesamten
region wieder gestiegen ist wir wissen
dass es
nationalistische und separatistische
kräfte gibt die von russland unterstützt
werden gerade im benachbarten serbien
aber auch in der bosnisch-serbischen
republik srpska und die sind im aufwind
sie blockieren reformprozesse sie
gefährden fortschritte der letzten 20
jahre und deshalb tragen wir mit diesem
café ansatz auch so geht dafür dass die
bundeswehr schnell dass sie flexibel
reagieren kann dass sie auch bereit
steht wenn sich die sicherheitslage
verschlechtert meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren mit den
bundeswehreinsätzen im kosovo und in
bosnien-herzegowina setzen wir heute als
bundestag klare zeichen der westbalkan
ist eine priorität der deutschen
außenpolitik und im übrigen nicht erst
seit dem besuch des bundeskanzlers vor
vier wochen in kosovo in serbien und
mazedonien sondern bereits seit
2014 mit dem berliner prozess wir haben
heute mehr denn je ein interesse ein
nachhaltiges interesse an der stabilität
der sicherheit und dem fortschritt für
diese region und deshalb geht es uns
auch darum dass wir glaubhafte dass wir
greifbare fortschritte für das kosovo
für die balkanstaaten erreichen sie
perspektivisch in die europäische union
aufzunehmen
glaubwürdig verlässlich auf beiden
seiten gerade in dieser
auseinandersetzung mit russland hat der
kosovo und seine regierung eindeutig
stellung bezogen die unterstützung aller
maßnahmen und sanktionen gegen russland
angezeigt sie sind ein verlässlicher
partner an unsere und andere seite der
europäischen und der internationalen
gemeinschaft und deshalb brauchen sie
diese eu beitrittsperspektive sie
brauchen endlich die visafreiheit und
sie müssen endlich mitglied im europarat
daten meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren wirkliche stabilität wird es im
kosovo aber erst dann geben wenn es
gelingt die politischen und die
ethnischen spannungen zu überwiegen der
eu geführte normalisierung des dialog
ist dafür der richtige weg die jetzt
jüngst unterzeichnete
energiepartnerschaft für den serbisch
dominierten norden ist deshalb ein
erster wichtiger schritt wir werden aber
noch weitere schritte brauchen zur
vollendeten ansturm dabei haben die den
kosovo unterstützen der kv einsatz
leistet dafür einen wichtigen beitrag
den ersetzt rahmenbedingungen wollen
dafür auch noch und deshalb stimmen wir
der verlängerung des café mein platz zu
gehen und alles andere hätte mich jetzt
auch persönlich überrascht so der
nächste redner ist josip juratovic von
der spd und er müsste auch der letzte
redner in dieser debatte sein
ich bitte um so stimmung
diesem antrag folgen den demokratischen
parteien in dem haus in die verzichte
bewusst jetzt auch meinen redemanuskript
kollegen und kolleginnen dass man die
von der rechten seite nicht ernst nehmen
kann das haben sie heute nacht bewiesen
aber
dass der linke höre ich jetzt schon im
fünfte mandat und immer wieder diese
gleiche mantra om groß
und ich hatte nur eine frage die man mir
jetzt nicht beantworten muss mit auch
nicht kann aber den sommerpause nutzen
kann dazu sich einmal gedanken darüber
zu machen dass man einfach endlich mal
wahrnimmt dass dieser nato einsatz
verhinderung einen massenmord es war und
dem milosevic klar gesagt wurde er hat
zu wählen entweder dem kosovo wieder
autonomie zurückzugeben oder nato muss
kurzum beschützen
das ist ein nato-einsatz
hat stattgefunden als jugoslawien nicht
mehr da es gab ein recht junges tragen
was auch jemand das war aber jugoslawien
gab es nicht mehr von dem her von
irgendwelchen beschlüssen über ein land
das nicht existiert das ist etwas
schwach und das habe ich übrigens dass
adam ilic missbraucht und drittens wäre
es ihnen lieber gewesen
wenn wir zugeschaut hätten dass es ein
zweites srebrenica passiert und er
möglicherweise das was passiert ist wie
in ruanda dass wir drei monate auf
resolutionen kaltband bombentrichter
haben um eine million menschen
geschlachtet wurden wer ihnen das leben
auf dem balkan
bitte überlegen sie darüber genau und
sie haben diese zeit jetzt ihrer
sommerpause im herbst diskutieren gerne
weiter dankeschön
damit viel applaus aus den reihen der
cdu nicht von den ampel fraktionen
alleine und jetzt wenn wir mal zu jetzt
gibt nämlich eine namentliche abstimmung
dazu kommen zur abstimmung über die
beschlüsse empfehlungen des auswärtigen
ausschusses die den antrag der
bundesregierung zur fortsetzung der
beteiligung deutscher streitkräfte an
den nationalen sicherheits präsenz im
kosovo kfor der ausschuss empfiehlt in
seiner beschlussempfehlung auch
drucksache 2647 den antrag der
bundesregierung auf drucksache 19 mai
1976 anzunehmen wir stimmen diese
beschlussempfehlung namentlich ab die
abstimmung erfolgt in der west lobby
sie haben
zur abgabe ihrer stimme nach eröffnung
der abstimmung 20 minuten zeit ich bitte
die schriftführung und schriftführer die
vorgesehenen plätze einzunehmen
ich höre die urnen sind besetzt ich
hoffe die namentliche abstimmung durch
beschlussempfehlungen auch drucksache
2647 die abstimmungs bohrungen werden um
12 uhr 45
geschlossen
das bevorstehende ende der namen
abstimmung wird ihnen rechtzeitig
bekannt gegeben ja und das prozedere
meine damen und herren das kennen wir ja
auch schon die das prozedere meine damen
kennen wir schon die namentliche
abstimmungen die abgeordneten verlassen
jetzt den saal und werfen draußen dann
ihre stimmkarten in die ohren es geht um
die verlängerung des kv mandates eines
der ältesten mandate diesen dass die
bundeswehr mit vorsieht mit bis zu 400
soldaten soll es ein weiteres jahr gehen
es ist eine internationale mission 28
nationen sind beteiligt im moment drei
1400 soldaten dort stationiert 70 davon
von der bundeswehr und das ganze stütze
nach wie vor auf die resolution 12 44
vom un-sicherheitsrat aus dem 10 juni
1999 im dezember 2018 räumte die
bundeslade wer damals das feldlager in
größeren und die 70 verbliebenen
soldaten sind jetzt noch in pristina